This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Ask yourself what makes you happy. Many people would say spending time with close friends, quality moments with family, playing with a pet. Most of us can agree, relationships are at the heart of a life well-lived. Social science research bears this out. Countless studies suggest that our emotional ties to others shape our well-being. Long-running analyses that track people over time show that social connections are not
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。问问自己是什么让你快乐。许多人会说是和密友共度时光，与家人共度美好时刻，或是和宠物玩耍。大多数人都会认同，人际关系是一段美好生活的核心。社会科学研究也证实了这一点。无数研究表明，我们与他人的情感联系塑造了我们的幸福感。长期追踪人们的研究表明，社交连接不仅仅
just about our emotional well-being, they're important determinants of our physical health. But it's one thing to say that relationships are important. It's another to go about getting them or preserving them. Life-long friends move away to other towns and countries. Romantic relationships come undone. Relatives pass away. And especially as people get older, many find it difficult to form new relationships, even as they yearn to feel close to others.
关乎我们的情感幸福感，它们也是决定我们身体健康的重要因素。但认为人际关系重要是一回事，着手去建立或维系它们则是另一回事。一生的挚友会搬到其他城镇和国家。浪漫关系会破裂。亲戚会离世。特别是随着人们年龄增长，许多人发现建立新关系很困难，尽管他们渴望感受到与他人的亲近。
New psychological research suggests a solution to this problem, or at least a partial solution, and it's one that's easily accessible to everyone. Last week, we kicked off our Relationships 2.0 series with a look at how to make conflicts less stressful and more productive. This week on Hidden Brain, a user's manual on how to boost your social connections and your happiness. Riggerist studies suggest that the problem of loneliness is growing around the world. Many people feel they don't have others in whom they can confide. Making friends can be hard, especially if you are someone who is naturally shy.
新的心理学研究为这个问题提供了一个解决方案，或者至少是一个部分解决方案，而且这是一个每个人都能轻易接触到的方法。上周，我们启动了“人际关系 2.0”系列节目，探讨了如何减少冲突带来的压力并提高其建设性。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨一份关于如何增强社交连接和幸福感的用户手册。越来越多的研究表明，孤独问题正在全球范围内加剧。许多人觉得身边没有可以倾诉的人。交朋友可能很难，尤其是如果你是一个天生害羞的人。
At the University of Sussex, psychologists' Gillian Sanström studies what we can do to combat the growing challenge of social isolation. Julian Sandstrom, welcome to Hidden Bre. Hi, thanks for having me. Julian, I understand that you were somewhat introverted and shy as a child. Can you describe the younger version of yourself to me? I was definitely a shy kid. Very bookish, and so I remember, you remember any time we went to my grandma's house
在苏塞克斯大学，心理学家吉莉安·桑斯特姆研究了我们能做些什么来应对日益严峻的社会隔离挑战。吉莉安·桑斯特姆，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嗨，谢谢邀请我来。吉莉安，我听说你小时候有点内向和害羞。你能给我描述一下小时候的自己吗？我绝对是一个害羞的孩子。非常喜欢书，所以我还记得，你还记得我们去我奶奶家
for Christmas and all the cousins and aunts, nunkles were there, I would be often roomed somewhere with a book just finding the quietest place in the house, just sitting there reading. And my dream when I was a kid was that I would grow up and I would live on an island. I don't mean like a tropical island. I mean, an island that was just me,
过圣诞节时，所有的表兄弟姐妹、阿姨和叔叔都在那里，我经常会拿着一本书呆在某个房间里，找家里最安静的地方，只是坐在那里读书。我小时候的梦想是长大了能住在一个岛上。我不是指热带岛屿那种。我的意思是，一个只有我自己的岛，
my own island, where I had a big library and that was my dream. As a teenager, Julian's shyness intensified. It got to the point you found it difficult to even have routine phone conversations. Oh gosh, that was the worst and I felt like every time I did it, I would get off the phone as quickly as possible. And then my mom would say, well, did you ask this? Did you say that? And of course, I never did any of those things. And so it just felt really stressful and anxious about talking to someone on the phone.
我自己的岛，那里有一个大图书馆，那就是我的梦想。十几岁时，吉莉安的害羞情绪加剧了。甚至到了让你觉得连进行日常电话交谈都很困难的地步。哦天哪，那是段最糟糕的经历，我觉得每次打完电话，我都会以最快的速度挂断。然后我妈妈会说，好吧，你问了这个吗？你说了那个吗？当然，我从来没有做过任何那些事情。所以给别人打电话让我觉得压力非常大，也很焦虑。
And I understand this must have been especially hard for you because you had one member of your family who was the polar opposite of you. Tell me about your dad. Yeah, actually, I feel like my who was the polar opposite of you. Tell me about your dad. Yeah, actually, I feel like my whole family was the opposite of me, but especially my dad. So my dad is just, I think he's sort of a king of talking to people. He had this knack for approaching people and starting, figuring out how to connect with them and start a conversation. And so anywhere we went would take a really long time,
而且我明白这一定对你特别难，因为你家里有一个成员跟你截然相反。跟我讲讲你爸爸吧。是的，其实，我觉得我的家里人都是我的反面，尤其是我的爸爸。所以我的爸爸，我觉得他简直是跟人聊天的大王。他有一种天赋，懂得如何接近他人并开始交流，弄清楚如何与他们建立联系并开启对话。所以我们无论去哪里都会花很长时间，
you know, growing to the grocery store would take three hours because he would stop and talk to everybody, especially kids, he loves talking to kids, he always teased them and get them talking. But he would ask a kid who looked like they were about five or six years old, he'd say, how old are you? 12, 13. You know, just something ridiculous that
你知道的，去杂货店买东西要花三个小时，因为他会停下来和每个人聊天，特别是小孩子，他特别喜欢和小孩说话，他总是逗他们开心让他们开口。但他会问一个看起来大概五六岁的小孩，他会说：你多大了？12岁，13岁？你知道的，就是说一些荒谬的话，
would make them feel like they had to sort of disagree with what he'd said or he'd ask them, you know, if they had any pets at home and, and, you know, ask if they had a pet alligator or a pet hippopotamus, you know, just ridiculous things that would, that would make them respond. And did you really feel like you were embarrassed when he did these things? Did you try and prevent him from doing it? I definitely would say, Dad, you know, why are you, like, I couldn't understand the compulsion that he had, you know, like, why are you doing this, Dad? They don't want to talk to you, you know, they're doing their grocery shopping, you know, why would someone want to stop and talk to a complete stranger? And what would he say in response? He would just ignore me
会让他们觉得好像不得不反驳他的话，或者他会问他们，你知道，家里有没有宠物，然后，你知道，问他们有没有宠物短吻鳄或宠物河马，你知道，就是一些荒谬的事情，会让他们做出回应。当你爸爸做这些事情时，你真的觉得很尴尬吗？你有没有试过阻止他？我绝对会说，爸爸，你知道，你为什么，就像，我无法理解他那种强迫行为，你知道，就像，你为什么这么做，爸爸？他们不想跟你说话，你知道，他们在买杂货呢，你知道，为什么有人会停下来和一个完全陌生的人聊天？他会怎么回答？他会直接忽略我
and enjoy his conversation because he was having such a good time. He likes to say, you know, everybody has a story. So he just loves meeting people and having a chat. As an adult, Gillian's desire to fade into the wallpaper began to have real consequences. So I was, I think, about 25 and I was on the plane, on my own, on this business trip, which seemed quite exciting. And I just recently got married, so I'd taken on my husband's surname, and they were making an announcement about a bunch of different people's names being called out,
然后享受他的对话，因为他玩得太开心了。他常说，每个人都有一个故事。所以他就是喜欢结识新朋友并闲聊。成年后，吉莉安融入背景、不引人注目的愿望开始带来真正的后果。所以当时我大概25岁，正独自坐飞机去进行一次商务旅行，这看起来挺令人兴奋的。我刚结婚不久，所以我用了我丈夫的姓氏，他们正在广播播报呼叫一堆不同人的名字，
something to do with baggage. I didn't know what was going on, but at some point they said, you know, would passenger sandstorm please identify themselves? And I thought, well, they couldn't mean me because, you know, that's not my name anymore. And I knew I should have checked, but I was too anxious and embarrassed to push that button and call over the flight attendant. So I didn't say anything. And so of course what happened is I got to the other end, got off the plane, went to the belt to collect my luggage, and of course it wasn't there. And so I had to go and buy a tourist t-shirt, which is what I wore to the first day on this business trip. I'm this business trip. Several years after the luggage incident, Jillian signed up for a graduate program in Toronto.
跟行李有关。我不知道发生了什么，但他们在某个时候说，请乘客桑斯特姆确认自己的身份。我想，嗯，他们不可能是在叫我，因为，你知道，那已经不是我的姓了。我知道我应该去确认一下，但我太焦虑和尴尬了，不敢按那个按钮把空乘叫过来。所以我什么都没说。所以当然发生的事情是，我到了目的地，下了飞机，走到行李提取转盘去拿行李，当然行李不在那儿。所以我不得不去买了一件游客T恤，这就是我参加这次商务旅行第一天穿的衣服。行李事件过去几年后，吉莉安在多伦多报名了一个研究生项目。
She had been working as a computer programmer for a decade, but wanted to try something new. She decided to get a master's degree in psychology. Jillian was in her 30s. As she looked around at her graduate school cohort, she worried she wasn't smart enough. But on top of all that, I had the feeling, you know, I'd given up this other career that had been going really well, you know, did I make the right decision? Should I be here? You know, all these people are so much younger than me. So it's just this feeling, you know, kind of imposter syndrome feeling of, you know,
她做了一十年电脑程序员，但想尝试新事物。她决定去攻读心理学硕士学位。当时的吉莉安已经30多岁了。当她环顾身边的研究生同学时，她担心自己不够聪明。但最重要的是，我有这种感觉，你知道的，我放弃了另一份发展得很好的职业，你知道，我做出正确的决定了吗？我应该来这里吗？你知道，所有这些人比我年轻得多。所以就是这种感觉，某种程度上的冒名顶替综合症的感觉，你知道的，
did I make the right decision? Should I be here? Soon enough, however, Jillian settled into a routine. It gave her more than structure. It gave her an insight. I would go to the research lab to do my studies, but then my supervisor had an office in a different
我做出了正确的决定吗？我应该来这里吗？然而，没过多久，吉莉安就适应了日常生活。这给她的不仅仅是结构。它给了她一种顿悟。我会去研究实验室做研究，但后来我的导师在另一个
building. And so when I walked between those two buildings, I would pass on the street corner, there was a hot dog stand because I was at a university right downtown Toronto. And I started to develop, sort of accidentally, develop a relationship with a lady who worked at the hot dog stand that I would pass by. And seeing her there and knowing that she recognized me, you know, we'd smile, we'd wave, I don't even know if we talked to each other, but we just had this relationship built on these little minimal signs. On some days, as Julian crossed the street, she noticed something curious. The hot dog lady was not at her usual spot.
大楼里有办公室。所以当我走在那两栋大楼之间时，我会在街角路过一个热带热狗摊，因为我在多伦多市中心的大学里。我开始，有点偶然地，与那个在热狗摊工作的女士建立起了一种关系，我经常路过那里。看到她在那儿，知道她认出我了，你知道的，我们会微笑，会挥手，我甚至不知道我们有没有和彼此说话，但我们确实建立了一种建立在这些微小的、最少信号之上的关系。有些日子里，当吉莉安过马路时，她注意到了一些奇怪的事情。热狗女郎不在她平时的地方。
That wasn't what was curious. The thing that struck Jillian was her own emotional reaction. So, on a day when I didn't see the hot dog lady, I would feel disappointed and kind of not lonely, but sort of unmoored, you know, because I think it came to think that the hot dog lady and people like her, like, we have lots of relationships like that, these little tiny relationships
奇怪的不是这个。让吉莉安触动的是她自己的情绪反应。所以，在没有看到热狗女郎的日子里，我会感到失望，而且有点说不上是孤独，但有点像失去依靠，你知道的，因为我觉得我开始认为热狗女郎和像她这样的人，就像，我们有很多这样的小关系，这些微不足道的小关系
that maybe don't seem particularly important. But I feel like you're kind of woven into the social fabric, you know? And so I felt a bit unmoored and uncentored when she was missing. I felt a bit unmoored and uncentered when she was missing. So, Jillian, when you think about these relationships that you're talking about, like your relationship with the hard dog lady,
可能看起来并不是特别重要。但我觉得你被编织进了社会结构里，你知道吗？所以当她不在的时候，我感到有点失去依靠和失去重心。当她不在的时候，我感到有点失去依靠和失去重心。那么，吉莉安，当你想到你所说的这些关系时，比如你和热狗女郎的关系，
they are different than the kind of relationships you would have with a spouse or a child, or even a colleague at work. And sociologists have come up with names for these kinds of relationships. Can you talk about the different terms they names for these kinds of relationships. Can you talk about the different terms they use for these kinds of relationships? Yes, so a sociologist in the 70s,
它们不同于你与配偶或孩子、甚至是工作同事的关系。社会学家为这些关系起了名字。你能谈谈他们为这些关系起的名字吗？你能谈谈他们为这些关系使用的不同术语吗？是的，所以70年代的一位社会学家，
named Mark Granavetter coined these kind of relationships, weak ties, and as opposed to strong ties, which are the ones with close friends and family. And it's tricky to come up with a definition, because one of the original thoughts was there are people that we see less often, but I don't think that's necessarily true because people like the hot dog lady I would see here on a very regular basis or you might run into someone at the school drop off every day.
名叫马克·格兰诺维特，他创造了这类关系的词汇，叫做弱连结，这与强连结相对，后者是我们与密友和家人的关系。要给它下一个定义很棘手，因为最初的想法之一是这些人我们见面的频率较低，但我觉得这不一定正确，因为像热狗女郎这样的人我会非常定期地见到，或者你可能会每天在学校接送孩子的地方偶遇某人。
So I don't think frequency is necessarily a factor here, but definitely close friends and family are the people that you feel the most comfortable with and you'd be most willing to share your deepest, darkest secrets with. But, you know, weak ties are, you know, you can feel fondly towards them positively, but you're probably less likely to feel like you'd want to confide in them and share something that feels very personal. So a little while later you were starting a PhD, and I believe this was in the lab of Elizabeth Don who we've previously had on Hidden Brain as a guest and and Liz Don asked you what you wanted to study and how did you respond? I
所以我认为频率不一定是这里的决定因素，但毫无疑问，密友和家人是你感到最舒适、最愿意与他们分享你内心最深处秘密的人。但是，你知道，弱连结是，你知道的，你可以对他们抱有好感，但你可能不太觉得自己想向他们吐露心声，分享非常私人的事情。所以不久之后你开始读博士，我相信这是在伊丽莎白·多恩的实验室里，我们之前请她做过《隐藏的大脑》的嘉宾，莉兹·多恩问你想研究什么，你是怎么回答的？我
Said I wanted to study the hot dog lady I said she said what makes you happy, you know That's her lab is the happy lab what makes you happy and, well, the hot dog lady makes me happy, you know, having these little interactions throughout my day with people that I'm not really close to and would never invite over for a drink or anything, but having this familiarity and feeling of connection with those kind of people just really feels good to me.
说我想研究热狗女郎，我说，她问什么能让你快乐，你知道的，她的实验室就是快乐实验室，什么能让你快乐，嗯，热狗女郎让我快乐，你知道的，在我的日常生活中与那些我并不是真的很亲密、绝不会邀请来喝一杯的人进行这些微小的互动，但和这种人有这种熟悉感和连接感真的让我感觉很好。
And I wanted to know, you know, is it just me or is this a more general thing to do people generally feel good from having these kind of relationships? When we return, how the people we least expect to matter in our lives can have a profound impact on the way we experience the world. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When you think about the most important people in your life, you probably think about a spouse, or a best friend, your children, maybe even a beloved pet. Chances are, you don't give much thought to the people on the periphery, the woman selling hard dogs on your way to work, the person sitting across from you on a train.
我想知道，你知道的，这只是我个人的感受，还是普遍现象？人们通常从拥有这些关系中感觉良好吗？当我们回来时，将探讨那些我们在生活中最意想不到的人，如何对我们体验世界的方式产生深远的影响。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当你想到你生命中最重要的人时，你可能会想到配偶、最好的朋友、你的孩子，甚至是你心爱的宠物。很有可能，你不会去多想那些边缘人物，上班路上卖热狗的妇女，火车上坐在你对面的人。
Even when we encounter these people every day, we often ignore them. If our lives were a movie, they wouldn't even be supporting characters. They are the extras. Jillian Sandstrom is a psychologist at the University of Sussex. She studies these relationships and why they are much richer than most of us think. Jillian some time ago you ran an interesting experiment involving a little tool called the clicker. Tell me about that study. I wanted to know, you know, does the number of interactions that people have with weak ties sort of relate to their happiness. So my hypothesis was, you know,
即使我们每天都遇到这些人，我们也经常忽视他们。如果我们的生活是一部电影，他们甚至连配角都算不上。他们只是群演。吉莉安·桑斯特姆是苏塞克斯大学的心理学家。她研究这些关系，以及为什么它们比我们大多数人想象的要丰富得多。吉莉安，不久前你做了一个有趣的实验，涉及一个小工具，叫做计数器。跟我讲讲那个研究。我想知道，你知道的，人们与弱连结的互动次数是否与他们的幸福感有关。所以我的假设是，你知道的，
given my personal experience, maybe on the days that you have more interactions with weak ties, you feel a little bit happier. So I got students at first and then later, just members of the community, to carry around two clickers, sort of in their pocket, two different colors. And every time that they talk to someone throughout the day, they were supposed to click. So one of the clickers was to count their interactions
根据我个人的经验，也许在你与弱连结有更多互动的日子里，你会觉得稍微更快乐一些。所以我让学生，后来又让社区成员，随身携带两个计数器，放在口袋里，两种不同的颜色。他们在一整天中每次跟别人说话时，都应该按一下。所以其中一个计数器用来计算他们的互动，
with strong ties. That would be people like you just mentioned, you know, a close friend or family member. And then the other clicker was to count the number of interactions they had with weak ties. If a volunteer smiled at someone they didn't know very well on their way to class, click Weak Ty. If they had a conversation of a lunch with their best friend, click Strong Ty. And as you'd expect, you know, the number of interactions you had with your close others, your strong ties, predicted happiness and feelings of belonging, but also independently the number of interactions that people had with weak ties also mattered.
对象是强连结。那会是你刚才提到的人，你知道的，密友或家庭成员。然后另一个计数器用来计算他们与弱连结的互动次数。如果一个志愿者在去上课的路上对一个不太熟的人微笑，点击弱连结。如果他们和最好的朋友共进午餐并交谈，点击强连结。正如你所料，你知道的，你与亲密之人的互动次数，即你的强连结，预示着幸福感和归属感，但除此之外，人们与弱连结的互动次数也很重要。
So on average, people who tended to have more interactions on a given day with weak ties tend to be a little happier than people who have fewer interactions with weak ties. But then also, regardless of what your personal average is, on a day when you talk to a few more weak ties than you usually do, you tend to be a little happier than you usually are. So Julian, we talked earlier about the sociologist Mark Ranoveta and his work on weak ties. If I recall correctly, he had a famous paper called The Strength of weak ties.
所以平均而言，在给定的一天中倾向于与弱连结有更多互动的人，往往比与弱连结互动较少的人要稍微快乐一些。但不仅如此，不管你个人的平均水平如何，在某一天，当你与弱连结交谈的次数比平时多一点时，你往往会比平时稍微快乐一点。所以吉莉安，我们之前谈到了社会学家马克·格兰诺维特及其关于弱连结的研究。如果我没记错的话，他有一篇著名的论文叫做《弱连结的力量》。
Looking at how, in some ways, are connections to people who are peripheral in our lives, are actually very important to us. And this has been borne out in lots of studies, looking at how, if you're searching for a new job, for example, you're much more likely to find that job through a network of weak ties of people whom you know slightly compared to the network of people who are very close to you. So, groundwater and others have looked primarily at the power of weak ties in the context of professional relationships, but in some ways what you were realizing from the
探讨了在某些方面，我们与生活中边缘人物的联系对我们其实非常重要。这一点在很多研究中得到了证实，比如如果你在寻找一份新工作，你会更有可能通过一个弱连结网络找到工作，也就是那些你只是略有了解的人，相比于那些与你非常亲密的人组成的网络。所以，格兰诺维特和其他人主要在职业关系的背景下探讨了弱连结的力量，但在某些方面，你从
clicker study was that the strength of weak ties might also affect our social lives and our emotional well-being. So, yeah, I was looking at weak ties as having other advantages that maybe hadn't been looked at before. So, these well-being benefits and emotional benefits. So, the biggest source of weak ties comes from the world of strangers of people we don't know. Can we talk a moment about whether there's a difference between strangers and weak ties? I mean what's the difference between someone who we would call a stranger and someone we would call a weak tie? I think the difference is
计数器研究中意识到的是，弱连结的力量可能也会影响我们的社交生活和情感幸福感。所以，是的，我一直在研究弱连结所具备的其他优势，这些优势以前可能没有被研究过。也就是这些幸福益处和情感益处。所以，弱连结的最大来源来自于陌生人的世界，也就是我们不认识的人。我们能花一点时间讨论一下陌生人和弱连结之间是否有区别吗？我的意思是，我们称之为陌生人的人和我们称之为弱连结的人有什么区别？我认为区别在于
actually pretty small. So I think a weak tie, my definition is just someone with whom you have sort of mutual familiarity. So the hot dog lady was a week tie. The first time I talked to her, she was a stranger. But when we saw each other again and she recognized me and I recognized her, I think at that point, she's no longer a stranger. She is a week tie. You started to conduct other studies besides the clicker study looking at the power of weak ties. Can you talk about some of that work? One of your studies I understand took place in a coffee shop.
其实相当小。所以我觉得一个弱联系，我的定义就是那种你们之间有一种熟悉感的人。所以热狗女郎就是一个弱联系。我第一次和她说话时，她是个陌生人。但当我们再次见面，她认出了我，我也认出了她，我觉得在那一刻，她不再是陌生人了。她是一个弱联系。除了点击器研究之外，你还开始进行其他研究来探讨弱联系的力量吗？你能谈谈其中一些工作吗？我了解到你的其中一项研究是在一家咖啡馆进行的。
Right, so I sort of inspired by the hot dog lady. I thought the closest thing I could think of, you know, I really wanted to study that phenomenon and I was aware that thing I could think of, you know, I really wanted to study that phenomenon. And I was aware that that lots of people have sort of their favorite barista at the coffee shop and people go into the coffee shop and the person knows their name and knows what their regular order is and it makes you feel really good. And so I really wanted to study that phenomenon. So I asked people, I recruited people walking past a Starbucks in Vancouver, gave them a gift card, and I said the only catch is that when you go in to buy your coffee, you have to follow some instructions.
对，所以我有点受到热狗女郎的启发。我想我能想到的最接近的事情，你知道，我真的很想研究那个现象，而且我意识到我能想到的事情，你知道，我真的很想研究那个现象。而且我意识到，很多人在咖啡馆里都有他们最喜欢的咖啡师，人们走进咖啡馆，那个人知道他们的名字，知道他们常点的饮品，这会让你感觉非常棒。所以我真的很想研究这个现象。于是我问了一些人，我招募了走过温哥华一家星巴克的人，给他们一张礼品卡，我对他们说，唯一的条件是当你进去买咖啡时，你必须按照一些指示去做。
And some people, the instructions where, you know, when you go in to buy your coffee, just be as efficient as possible. And I tried to tell people this would be a good thing. The burst is busy and just wants to get through their day and you'd be helping them out. So have your money ready and avoid unnecessary conversation. I mean, you have to talk to place your order. And then the other group of people, I said, okay, when you go in, try to turn it into a real genuine social interaction. So smile, make eye contact, and have a little chat. And you know, plenty of said they'd do this anyway. And I said, well, just amp it up. It did even more than you usually do.
对于一些人，指示是，你知道，当你进去买咖啡时，尽量表现得最高效。我试图告诉这些人这会是一件好事。咖啡师很忙，只想快点完成工作，你这样是在帮他们。所以准备好钱，避免不必要的对话。我的意思是，你为了点单还是得说话。然后对于另一组人，我说，好吧，当你进去时，试着把它变成一个真正真诚的社交互动。所以要微笑，有眼神交流，聊聊天。你知道，很多人说他们本来就会这样做。我说，那就再加把劲。比你平时做得更多。
And so people bought their coffee, followed the instructions. And then when they came out, I asked them to fill out a short survey. And what we found was that people who'd had this just tiny little social interaction, had treated the barista as if they would treat one who knew their name and knew their order. If they had that social interaction, they were in a better mood and they felt more satisfied with their Starbucks experience and they felt a greater sense
于是人们买咖啡，照着指示做了。然后当他们出来时，我请他们填写一份简短的问卷。我们发现的是，进行过这种微小社交互动的人，他们对待咖啡师的方式就像对待一个知道他们名字和订单的人一样。如果他们有了那次社交互动，他们的心情会更好，对星巴克的体验会更满意，并且会感到更强烈的感觉
of connection to other people. In Julian study, people had an incentive to talk to strangers. In the real world, talking to people you don't know can be awkward. We worry our small talk won't be well received. We fear that people will think we're obnoxious, silly or unlikable. We've talked about this trepidation on the show before. In our episode featuring the psychologist Erika Boothby, she called it the Liking Gap. It's the gap between how we believe others see us and what they actually see. Julien has found evidence of the liking gap phenomenon in her own research.
与其他人建立连接。在朱莉安的研究中，人们有动力和陌生人交谈。在现实世界中，和不认识的人说话可能会很尴尬。我们担心我们的闲聊不会受欢迎。我们害怕别人会觉得我们讨厌、愚蠢或不讨人喜欢。我们以前在节目中讨论过这种不安。在我们采访心理学家埃里卡·布思比（Erika Boothby）的那期节目中，她称之为“喜欢差距”（Liking Gap）。这是我们认为别人如何看待我们与他们实际看到我们的情况之间的差距。朱莉安在自己的研究中也发现了“喜欢差距”现象的证据。
What we find is that after two people talk for the first time, they each tend to think that the other person liked them less than they actually did. So, you know, we have this negative voice in our head that says, oh, you know, why did I say that? Why did I not say that? Did, you know, did they understand me? Did I embarrass myself? And we tend to listen to that negative voice and think that everything went horribly wrong. But our partner doesn't have that say, you know, they're probably doing the same thing, right? So they don't even notice the thing that you
我们发现，当两个人第一次交谈后，他们每个人往往都觉得对方比实际情况更不喜欢自己。所以，你知道，我们脑子里有一个消极的声音在说，哦，你知道，我为什么要那样说？我为什么不那样说？你知道，他们理解我吗？我出丑了吗？我们往往会听信那个消极的声音，认为一切都糟透了。但我们的伙伴并没有这种想法，你知道，他们可能在做同样的事情，对吧？所以他们甚至不会注意到你
think went horribly wrong because they're stuck in their own head thinking about what they did wrong. And so I read the abstract that Erica was part of where she was talking about the liking gap. And I thought, oh, I have data, we should talk. And so I reached out to her via email and we've been collaborating ever since. So it's a great example of reaching out to a stranger. I'm wondering, Jillian, if you can talk a moment
认为糟糕透顶的事情，因为他们深陷在自己的脑海里，想着自己哪里做错了。于是我读了埃里卡参与的那篇摘要，里面谈到了喜欢心愿差距。我想，哦，我有数据，我们应该谈谈。于是我通过电子邮件联系了她，从那以后我们一直在合作。所以这是一个与陌生人接触的好例子。朱莉安，我想知道你能否花点时间谈谈
about how our intuitions and forecasting errors are sometimes compounded by the messages we receive from society. I want to play you an old public service announcement about how children should think about strangers. Most people love a little child. Some grownups though are bad. The bad ones look like good ones, like any mom or dad. So that is why you must not talk to strangers that you meet. Don't let them give you any toys or anything to eat.
关于我们的直觉和预测错误有时是如何因我们从社会接收到的信息而加剧的。我想放一段关于儿童应该如何看待陌生人的旧公共服务广告。大多数人都喜欢小孩子。不过有些成年人是坏人。坏人看起来像好人，就像任何爸爸妈妈一样。这就是为什么你千万不要和遇到的陌生人说话。不要让他们给你任何玩具或任何吃的东西。
If someone that you do not know should offer you a treat, remember how he looks and talks, but run fast stop the street. Run fast. So it's not just our internal messaging that gets it wrong, Julian. Sometimes the external messaging is also saying, keep to yourself. Yes, absolutely. And I think norms and those kind of cultural messages make a huge difference to what we do. I think it's really hard, isn't it? Because it's a very nuanced message that we want to convey. Because we don't want to make people scared to talk to others,
如果你不认识的人给你送来点心，记住他的样子和说话方式，但要快跑离开街道。快跑。所以朱莉安，不仅仅是我们的内部信息传达错了。有时外部信息也在说，管好你自己。是的，绝对是。我认为规范和那种文化信息对我们的行为有巨大的影响。我觉得这真的很难，对吧？因为我们想要传达的信息非常微妙。因为我们不想让人们害怕与他人交谈，
but we do need to be aware of our personal safety. And I'm not suggesting that people go down a dark alley and start talking to people, but in most situations, if you're in a public place surrounded by other people, there's so many benefits to talking to strangers. I'd like to talk about some of those benefits that you yourself have realized in your own life. You've actually tried to walk the talk of your research and practice what you've preached.
但我们确实需要注意个人安全。我并不是建议人们走进黑巷子去和别人说话，但在大多数情况下，如果你在一个被其他人包围的公共场所，和陌生人交谈有这么多的好处。我想谈谈你自己生活中意识到的一些好处。你实际上已经努力践行你的研究，将你宣扬的理念付诸实践。
Tell me about a time that you had an interesting conversation on the train with a woman who was carrying a very fancy cupcake. Yes, this was one of the first conversations that I can remember sort of deliberately starting with a stranger. And if I think about it, I've definitely had conversations before then, but this is one that was really memorable to me,
跟我讲讲有一次你在火车上和一个拿着一个非常精致的纸杯蛋糕的女士进行了一次有趣的对话。是的，这是我能记起的主动和陌生人开始的对话之一。如果我想想的话，在那之前我肯定也进行过对话，但这绝对是一个让我记忆深刻的对话，
I think because I felt like I deliberately done it rather than it just sort of happening accidentally. And so I was on the train in Toronto and it was sort of during the time when all these very fancy cupcake shops were coming out. And this woman on the train had this beautiful, just delicious looking, decadent cupcake. And so I couldn't help but ask her about it. Basically, I just wanted to comment on how beautiful this cupcake was. And so we started talking, and I think maybe it was her birthday or something,
我想是因为我觉得这是我有意为之，而不仅仅是偶然发生的。当时我在多伦多的火车上，正值所有这些非常精致的纸杯蛋糕店兴起的时候。火车上的那个女人拿着一个美丽、看起来极其美味、让人垂涎欲滴的纸杯蛋糕。所以我忍不住向她询问。基本上，我只是想评论一下这个纸杯蛋糕有多漂亮。于是我们开始交谈，我想那可能是她的生日或者别的什么，
and she was reminiscing about other birthdays, and she told me that in the past, she had gone on a trip to South Africa, and when she was there, she had ridden an ostrich. And you know, you think about it, how did we get from cupcakes to ostriches? I don't know. And so I was really hooked. I just thought, this is amazing. Like, I would never have known this if I hadn't talked to a complete stranger. Gillian, being a psychologist, went a step further. She realized that weak dives are a source of
她回忆起其他的生日，她告诉我，过去她曾去南非旅行过，在那里的时候，她骑过鸵鸟。你知道，你想想，我们是怎么从纸杯蛋糕聊到鸵鸟的？我不知道。所以我真的被吸引住了。我只是觉得，这太神奇了。如果不和完全陌生的人说话，我是绝对不会知道这些的。朱莉安作为一名心理学家，更进一步。她意识到弱联系是
novelty in our lives. Once she had this insight, it started to pop up all the time. Yeah, I've learned all sorts of things that, you know, I found interesting. Like, I remember talking to someone on a plane who was from Slovenia, who told me that Slovenia is 70% forest, and I thought, okay, someday I need to go to Slovenia because that sounds awesome. Forests are a great place for an introvert, right? I remember talking to someone on the bus at the university who told me that there was a region in China where the majority of people, or there was a huge number of people who have read hair like me, and I went home and googled it right away and found that indeed it was true. I have had free vegetables from people.
我们生活中的新奇事物。一旦她有了这个见解，它就不断涌现。是的，我了解到了各种各样的东西，你知道，我觉得很有趣。比如，我记得在飞机上和一位来自斯洛文尼亚的人交谈，他告诉我斯洛文尼亚70%都是森林，我想，好吧，总有一天我要去斯洛文尼亚，因为听起来太棒了。森林对内向的人来说是个好地方，对吧？我记得在大学的公共汽车上和一个人交谈，他告诉我中国有一个地区，那里的大多数人，或者有大量的人拥有像我一样红色的头发，我回家后马上上网搜索，发现确实如此。我从别人那里得到过免费蔬菜。
I got a ride from a couple of ones that saved me from having to, you know, the train wasn't running and so they gave me a ride so that I didn't have to take the bus instead of the train late at night. I was with my husband. I felt very safe about it. Again, not suggesting people get in a stranger's car, but I felt comfortable having talked to them for ages first. I joined a book club after talking to a stranger. I've talked all sorts of different interesting kinds of people. I've talked to free masons. I talked to someone who made theatrical
我有几次搭过别人的便车，这免去了我，你知道的，当时火车停运了，所以他们让我搭便车，这样我就不用在深夜坐公交车代替火车了。我和我丈夫在一起。我对此感到非常安全。再次声明，我不是建议人们上陌生人的车，但在和他们聊了很久之后，我感到很舒服。在和一个陌生人交谈后，我加入了一个读书俱乐部。我和各种各样有趣的人交谈过。我和共济会员交谈过。我和一个制作戏剧假发的人交谈过
wigs. I've talked to children's book authors and a poet, I don't know if just met all sorts of really interesting people and just had some really interesting conversations and also a lot of just sort of average meh conversations. We often fail to see the benefits of talking to strangers because of our own biases. We worry that people won't like us. We assume that small talk is empty talk. In reality, these interactions have a subtle but significant effect on our happiness. Weak dies it turns out offer tremendous value in our lives. But during the COVID-19 pandemic, many of us have experienced a catastrophic loss of these
我跟童书作家和诗人聊过，我不知道，只是遇到了各种各样非常有趣的人，进行了一些非常有趣的交谈，也有很多非常普通的、平淡无奇的交谈。由于我们自身的偏见，我们经常看不到与陌生人交谈的好处。我们担心别人会不喜欢我们。我们假设闲聊就是空洞的交谈。实际上，这些互动对我们的幸福感有着微妙但显著的影响。事实证明，弱联系为我们的生活提供了巨大的价值。但在2019冠状病毒病大流行期间，我们许多人都经历了灾难性的
connections. During the pandemic, people generally found ways to stay in touch with the people they were closest to. But with acquaintances, sometimes we don't even know how to reach them. They're just the people that we have been to cross paths with during the course of our day. So because the patterns of our day change, we just didn't see them. I had a Barry at the pet store who would remember me and recognize me and ask about my cats. I wouldn't reach out to Barry at the pet store, would I?
连接。在疫情期间，人们通常会想方设法与最亲近的人保持联系。但对于熟人，有时我们甚至不知道如何联系他们。他们只是我们在日常生活中碰巧擦肩而过的人。因此，由于我们的日常生活模式改变了，我们只是看不到他们了。我在宠物店里有一个叫巴里的店员，他会记得我、认出我并询问我的猫。我不会主动联系宠物店的巴里，对吧？
I mean, I don't even know how to do that. So I think we've kind of, the pandemic sort of disproportionately affected our relationships with weak ties. And at the same time, Julian, I think a lot of people are reporting. Even people who enjoy working from home and feel like working from home has actually allowed them to spend more time with family and better have a better work-life balance. Many people then report, I somehow feel cut off from the world in important ways. And perhaps part of what they're experiencing is what they're experiencing
我的意思是，我甚至不知道该怎么做。所以我想我们有点，疫情某种程度上不成比例地影响了我们与弱联系的关系。与此同时，朱莉安，我认为很多人都在报告。甚至那些喜欢在家工作、觉得在家工作实际上让他们有更多时间陪伴家人并更好地平衡工作与生活的人。许多人随后报告说，我不知何故在重要方面与世界隔绝了。也许他们正在经历的一部分是他们正在经历的
is what you're talking about here. Your spouse is still your spouse. Your child is still your child. Your co-worker is still your co-worker. And you have fixed ways of dealing with them. Weak ties are what bring in surprise and unpredictability into your life. I think that's true.
就是你在这里谈论的。你的配偶仍然是你的配偶。你的孩子仍然是你的孩子。你的同事仍然是你的同事。你有一套固定与他们相处的方式。弱联系是把惊喜和不可预测性带入你生活的东西。我认为这是真的。
And I think that that has a bigger or maybe different impact than people think. So during the pandemic, if we are talking to our close friends, we're probably already watching the same shows on Netflix, where we, you know, we already know all their opinions. We sort of have nothing new to talk about because nobody was able to go out and do new things. And so I think, you know, it's the weak ties that sort of get us access to new kinds of information or new stories or new adventures.
而且我认为这比人们想象的有着更大或不同影响。所以在疫情期间，如果我们和密友交谈，我们可能已经在Netflix上看相同的节目了，我们在，你知道的，我们已经知道他们所有的观点了。我们似乎没有什么新鲜事可谈，因为没有人能够出去做新事情。所以我想，你知道，正是弱联系让我们接触到新类型的信息、新故事或新冒险。
And because we were cut off from them, I think we really missed out on a huge portion of the novelty that we tend to get day to day. As we go about our daily routines, there are countless opportunities to connect with others. We often take these opportunities for granted, but long months of social distancing in the context of the pandemic make it clear that our lives are made richer by the people around us, even people we don't know very well at all. When we come back, techniques and strategies for making the most of our weekdice. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
因为我们与他们断了联系，我觉得我们真的错失了很大一部分我们日常倾向于获得的新奇感。当我们进行日常琐事时，有无数的机会与他人建立联系。我们经常认为这些机会是理所当然的，但在疫情背景下长达数月的社交距离让我们清楚地认识到，我们的生活因为周围的人而变得更加丰富，甚至包括那些我们根本不太熟悉的人。当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何充分利用弱联系的技术和策略。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Across a number of research studies, psychologist Jillian Sandstrom has found that people are happier when they have lots of casual conversations with strangers or people they know only slightly. The cafeteria worker who makes you a sandwich, the lifeguard who watches over your kids at the swimming pool, and usher at the theater. Most people don't prioritize these relationships, perhaps because they are fleeting. Jillian grew up shy, but has tried to become more outgoing in conversations with strangers. In recent
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。通过多项研究，心理学家朱莉安·桑德斯特姆（Jillian Sandstrom）发现，当人们与陌生人或仅有一面之缘的人进行大量随意的交谈时，他们会更快乐。为你做三明治的食堂工作人员，在游泳池看管你孩子的救生员，剧院的引座员。大多数人并不优先考虑这些关系，也许因为它们是短暂的。朱莉安性格内向，但一直在努力在与陌生人的交谈中变得更加外向。在最近的
years, she has developed something of a science on how to go about talking to strangers. She has discovered that there are distinct psychological problems in starting conversations, maintaining conversations and ending conversations, and each problem requires its own solution. She explained to me the challenge involved with breaking the ice. When I was doing my PhD, I used to talk to people on the bus all the time. And it wasn't a common thing to do. You don't talk to people on the bus. So when I would do that, I think people's original reaction, their initial gut reaction is, do I know you? I think that's, you know, they think, maybe that's why you're talking to me. Maybe I've met you before.
几年里，她总结出了一套关于如何与陌生人交谈的科学方法。她发现，在开启对话、维持对话和结束对话时，存在着截然不同的心理问题，每个问题都需要自己的解决方法。她向我解释了破冰所涉及的挑战。当我读博士时，我经常在公交车上和别人聊天。这不是一件常见的事。你不会在公交车上跟人聊天。所以当我这样做时，我想人们最初的反应，他们的第一直觉是，我认识你吗？我认为那是，你知道的，他们会想，也许这就是你跟我说话的原因。也许我以前见过你。
And then they realize, oh, I don't know you. And then they think, oh, what is happening here? What do you want? You know, what is going on? And then I think you get to the third phase, which is just, oh, you're being friendly. Cool. And then you have a nice chat.
然后他们意识到，哦，我不认识你。接着他们会想，哦，这怎么回事？你想要什么？你知道，发生什么事了？然后我认为你进入了第三阶段，也就是，哦，你很友好。酷。然后你们聊得很开心。
So I think sometimes people, you know, it's, you have to be aware that there is going to be that awkward moment because unfortunately it is just not the norm and so people have to sort of make sense of what's going on. But I think if you can be a little bit patient, you almost always get to that stage where people can accept that you're just being friendly. Breaking the ice involves, well, breaking the ice.
所以我认为有时人们，你知道，你必须意识到会有那种尴尬的时刻，因为不幸的是这根本不是常态，所以人们必须弄清楚发生了什么。但我认为如果你能多一点耐心，你几乎总是能达到那个阶段，人们会接受你只是在友好待人。破冰包括，嗯，破冰。
You have to accept there are going to be a few moments where the other person might be wary. There may also be situations where someone clearly does not want to be engaged in a chat. As they say, read the room. I can think of a time not too long ago when I was on the tube in London, and the unwritten rule is that you do not talk to people
你必须接受会有那么几个时刻，对方可能会保持警惕。也可能会有一些情况，某人显然不想参与聊天。正如他们所说，看懂眼色。我能想到不久前我在伦敦地铁上的一个经历，不成文的规定是你在地铁上
on the tube, so it's just breaking all of the norms to do it, but I've had some really great chats on the tube, so I just keep doing it. But I remember once being on the tube and turning to the person sitting on my right and trying to start a conversation. And she was polite, I think I started to say, you know, how are you if you had a busy day? And, you know, she responded, but it was very clear
不和别人说话，所以这样做完全打破了所有的规范，但我在地铁上进行过一些非常棒的聊天，所以我一直在这样做。但我记得有一次在地铁上，转过身去和坐在我右边的人说话，试图发起对话。她很礼貌，我想我开始说，你知道，你好吗，你今天过得很忙吗？而且，你知道，她回答了，但很明显
from her body language that she just did not want to talk. She was getting out of book and sort of getting herself set up and plugged in whatever. And so I thought, okay, that's fine. You know, I, I don't think we should push ourselves on people. And so I literally turned my head to the person sitting on my left and I started talking to them and we had a really nice chat. People worry too much about rejection because first of all, I don't know why that woman didn't want to talk to me, but you know, there's 100 reasons and I could choose to believe that she didn't like me or something about me, but I could also choose to believe that, you know, like I said, maybe she's shy, maybe she's anxious,
从她的肢体语言来看，她根本不想聊天。她拿出一本书，开始整理自己，插上耳机之类的。所以我想，好吧，没关系。你知道，我，我认为我们不应该把自己的意愿强加给别人。所以我 literalmente（原文为 literally，此处指字面意思/直接）把头转向坐在我左边的人，开始和他们聊天，我们聊得很开心。人们对拒绝感到过分担心，因为首先，我不知道为什么那个女人不想跟我说话，但你知道，有一百个理由，我可以选择相信她不喜欢我或我身上的某些特质，但我也可以选择相信，你知道的，就像我说的，也许她害羞，也许她焦虑
maybe she just really is reading an amazing book and you know, I get it. So, you know, I can choose to believe something that isn't so personally negative and just, you know, most people do wanna talk and you know, it didn't surprise me that the person on my left was a bit more willing. The second problem people face
in talking to strangers is in maintaining the conversation. If breaking the ice feels scary for many people, awkward silences can be terrifying. I think it helps to sort of pre-think, you know, what might I do if that happened? And it could be things like, well, I'll share something about myself or I'll comment on something that was in the news today or I'll ask them a question or, or I'll take a breath and just wait a moment, it'll be fine, but I have to make sure I don't panic.
That would be a good thing to think about. Sometimes Gillian says, the problem is not an awkward silence, but a perfectly interesting conversation that suddenly goes sideways. I saw this man with a net and he was scooping up fish. And I thought, what in the heck is he doing? And so I went up and I asked him, I said, what are you doing? And he said, he lived nearby. And he said, this happens sometimes,
we get a heavy rain and the fish sort of washed downstream and they get stuck somewhere. And then the water goes down and they're in big trouble. So I'm just catching the fish and moving them to somewhere where they're safe. And I thought, oh, this is amazing. This guy's a fish hero. And what a cool story. And so we continued talking and the conversation shifted away from the fish. And, you know, it was early days in the pandemic. So inevitably, we
ended up talking about that. And I discovered that he thought that the pandemic was a hoax and that the government was making up stories. And that's not my view. I couldn't understand why someone would think that way. Why would the government do that? And so I started to think, who is this person and what's going on here? Here they are, a fish hero. How is a fish hero also having these,
you know, you just never know someone, do you? And did you sort of sidele away from the conversation at that point, Jillian, what did you do? You know, I just think that we can serve a benefit to other people by talking to them and by listening to them. So I think it's pretty rare at least in my own experience. I don't tend to get into any kind of heated topics when I'm talking to a
complete stranger. It's usually fairly innocuous and fun. It doesn't get into politics and religion and all the heavy stuff that we avoid at the Thanksgiving dinner table. I'm just seeking out a fun interaction. I just let him talk a little bit, but yeah, it just sort of drew to a natural close and I moved on. Can you talk a little bit about how when we have conversations that are awkward or conversations that start off being interesting but end up in an odd place. Many of us draw the wrong conclusion from this, which is that the next conversation is also likely to be difficult, or the next conversation is likely to be unpleasant. In some ways, we overcount the likelihood of negative interactions.
So yeah, I've run a bunch of studies in the lab where I've asked people to predict how a conversation will go, then they actually have a conversation with a stranger and then they tell me how it went. And the people's worries before the conversation are quite high, but after having the conversation, they say, you know, none of those things actually happened. But if you asked them to predict what would happen if they had another conversation right now, those fears sort of creep back up, not all the way to the level that they were at before the study, but definitely higher than they should be based on having just had a pleasant conversation. So it seems that people have trouble generalizing, and you know, it makes some sense because every
human is unique, right? So it would be easy to think, well, just because I had a nice conversation with this person, why would I expect to have a nice conversation with the next person? Julian wanted to figure out if she could override people's tendency to undercount the likelihood of good conversations and overcount the risk of bad conversations. The only way I can think of to fix this would be to get people to have a lot of conversations so they can start to see a pattern, start to see that most of these conversations are pleasant. But how am I going to do that when people don't even want to have one conversation with a stranger, let alone lots? And so I kind of stole an idea.
I was thinking, you know, I need people to, I need to turn it into a game. I need to make it fun somehow. And so I was thinking, maybe I could turn it into a bingo game or something. But a researcher in my department had placed posters around the building. They were recruiting people for a study involving a scavenger hunt. And it was a study about memory. But I thought, oh, scavenger hunt, I could get people to do a scavenger hunt game that involves finding and talking to strangers. What was the scavenger hunt game that involves talking to strangers?
I thought scavenger hunts are about finding treasure. Well, people and conversations with strangers are treasure. Come on. So yeah, I came up with a list of missions that were things like, you know, find someone who's wearing a hat or find someone who's drinking a coffee. I came up with a whole list of missions, about 30 of them, and, you know, I wanted them to be easy. I didn't, you know, most Cavendor hunts, you're trying to make it a little tricky, so people
can't find everything, right? But I wanted people to be able to accomplish every single mission. Some volunteers were asked to merely observe the strangers they found. Others had to engage the strangers in conversation. We found that over the course of the study, every day, people reported being less and less worried about being rejected by the people they approached and more and more confident in their ability to start and maintain and end the conversation. And so it really did seem that there was this gradual
improvement and that repeated practice was important. Just having one conversation was not enough, it was this gradual improvement over time that stuck even a week after the scavenger hunt had ended, people still had more positive feelings towards talking to strangers. Julian McAnne to see how important it was to not just have the insight that talking to strangers could be fun, but to actually practice doing it. She has developed a workshop to get people to practice these skills.
It's called, how Talk to Strangers. The workshops sort of became research and then the research fed back into the workshops. But really, it's just a big practice session. You know, you're bringing in a bunch of people who think they'd like to learn more how to talk to strangers. And so before the workshop starts, it's very quiet in the room. There's crickets, because everyone feels a bit awkward
and they don't know what to do, what's gonna happen. And so I always start the workshop by just saying, okay, you have to turn to someone sitting next to you and just have a conversation right now. And then it's just this beautiful moment because there's this buzz in the room
and it's just like, oh my God, people are talking. And then it's really like, oh my God, people are talking. And then it's really hard to shut people up. Do you have icebreakers yourself that you've used, Jillian, in terms as you've become a better conversationalist and better at talking to strangers? What do you go up and talk to strangers about? How do you start a conversation?
What do you do? Yeah, I have a few different go-to methods now. So maybe it's especially an English thing. They joke about it all the time, but it's talk about the weather, right? And I think the reason we do that is because it's a shared circumstance, right? It's something we're both experiencing at the same time. So I think that principle can be used more broadly. So if you're in the same place as this person at the same time, then you have various things in common with them already. So you can comment on the shared situation
that you happen to be in. If you're on a bus or something and something unusual happens, then all of a sudden you're all on the same team, aren't you? Everybody talks when they never would have talked before because you've experienced this situation together. But sometimes I do it in a different way, which is by pointing out something that I'm seeing in the environment. So sometimes I'll point out happy, playful dogs to someone else that's walking past me in the park and just draw their attention to it, or I've pointed out the spring flowers that are popping up. But that's also linked to sort of the last sort of main technique I use, which
is just to tap into your curiosity. So I can't tell you how many conversations I've started just by going up to someone and saying, what you doing? Like I did with the fish hero, you know, I saw him scooping up fish in a net and I thought, what is he doing? And so I've gone up to lots of different people. I think you have to be a little careful because you don't want it to come across as accusatory.
It has to come across as curious. So you have to do it with the sort of, you know, lightness in your voice that it's, you know, just out of curiosity and fun rather than being an accusation. So there are been studies that found that conversations don't end when, you know, one party wants them to end. And they don't even end when one party wants them to end.
They don't even end when both parties want them to end, partly because people are so uncomfortable with terminating conversations. Conversations can go well past the point. They're enjoyable for either party. How do you get out of conversations with strangers, Julia? Yeah, I really am still trying to work that out. I mean, most of the time that I talk to strangers out walking around the park or something,
and it's really easy to just sort of walk away when you're finished. As opposed to being on a bus or sitting next to someone on the plane, people don't talk until it's 15 minutes before the landing because otherwise they're stuck there for the whole flight. But I've definitely gotten stuck in conversations and I feel like I'm still not very good at figuring out how to get out of them. And, you know, I've run these how to talk
to strangers workshops. And I, like I said earlier, people can come up with a hundred ways to start a conversation. Nobody really knows how to end them. Most of the time when people are brainstorming, it's just a list of lies. It's just, you know, I need to go to the bathroom. I need to make a phone call or texting a friend and asking a friend to call you in the middle of a conversation so that you can be pulled away. Right. Yes, we've all seen those episodes on TV. If you haven't heard from me, call me in seven minutes and help me get out of this. It depends on the situation, if it's a mixer and networking event where it's intended for people
to have talk to multiple partners, then there are some clever things you can do, like introduce the person to someone else and then move on. But when I've taught these workshops, it's always one person, and I think it's literally one person who says, you know, that they just thank the person for the conversation and sort of signal that it's over and it's time to move on and maybe even explicitly say that, you know. It's been nice talking to you, but I think it's time for us to go now. And everyone looks at this person and kind of says, you can do that.
So, you know, that tells me how uncommitted it is, but, you know, why not? So, I've definitely been trying to do that more often, is to just, you know, thank the person, acknowledge, you know, I think that's what we want, right? We don't, it's very unpleasant when you're talking to someone and instead of saying that, they just start looking around and you can see them kind of fidget, like that's the worst, right? It'll be much better if someone just said, thank you and, you know, I'm going to move on now. I'm wondering if at these workshops, Jillian, anyone ever brings up the question of gender. And I asked this question because some time ago we came by an interesting post on Reddit,
a trans man named Lysander Baker wrote that he had transitioned from female to male over the course of the pandemic and he'd noticed that his social interactions had changed. I want to play your clip of what he told us. It made me realize how difficult it was to try to socialize this casually as male because clip of what he told us. So Lysa did told us, Julien, that he felt that his license to talk to strangers had suddenly expired. My interactions with strangers changed mainly because the rules changed completely. Before I could get by with lighthearted jokes, you know, you know, one-off like
zingers, but after that started to become much more poorly received. So what do you make of this, Julian, this this mandate to talk to strangers? Is it some ways harder if you're a man compared to a woman? So at the how to talk to strangers workshops that I've run, I've heard those kind of comments from both genders actually. So women are nervous about talking to a man because they don't want to send the wrong signals. And men are worried about talking to women because they don't want to have their behavior interpreted in the wrong way. So yeah, I think everybody's sort of nervous about talking to each other. And it's really a shame, isn't it?
Because we don't want to not talk to half of the human population. But I don't think we have to get stuck there. Like I think there's probably things we can do in our body language to signal that, you know, by keeping some distance, maybe, you know, less intense eye contact. I think there's some probably some things we can do to signal that we're just being friendly and not, or we can explicitly say it, like, look, I'm not hitting on you. I'm just being friendly. We started this conversation, Julian, by talking about how you thought of
yourself and perhaps still think of yourself as being introverted. But I understand that partly partly maybe learning from your own experience as an adolescent or as a young person at parties, you now make it a habit to go up to the person who is standing by themselves in a corner at the party, the person who is clearly the introvert and actually strike up a conversation with them. Yeah, and there's a few reasons for that.
One is completely selfish because I'm very much an introvert and so that's still an environment that I don't feel comfortable in when there's a lot of people, especially when there's lots of people I don't know or it's a really kind of noisy environment. That's when I feel the most uncomfortable. And I know that the way to fix that, to make myself feel better, is to get into a one-to-one conversation with someone. But then in addition to that, I'd like to think that there's a pro-social motive as well. You look around the room and you see someone else who doesn't have anyone to talk to.
I know now that so many of us feel anxious, socially anxious or socially awkward. So there's guaranteed to be somebody else who doesn't really know anybody and doesn't have someone to talk to. And so I'll look around for that person and go and start a conversation with them. And so I'd like to think that it's helping both of us. So in many ways, Jillian, you grew up thinking of yourself as being shy and introverted.
And in some ways it's kind of remarkable how far you've come. You've really practiced changing your own behavior. Do you ever think to yourself, it's remarkable how far I've come and you've really practiced changing your own behavior. Do you ever think to yourself, it's remarkable how far I've come and how much I've changed? Just recently, actually, a couple of weeks ago, I had a moment where it really struck me how far I've come. So I was at the opera and I had come back from the intermission and I started chatting with the people
who were sitting next to me sort of farther in from the aisle than I was. And I said, how are you doing? And they said, fine, ish. And I thought, oh, something is really wrong. If a complete stranger admits that they're not just fine, right? And I said, you know, what's going on? And it turned out that the woman had Parkinson's and she was feeling very uncomfortable sitting where she was.
And she was worried that she might need to leave partway through the second act. But she was so far in from the aisle that it would mean disrupting everybody. She had thought that she would be sitting on the aisle. And so she was very upset to find out that she wasn't. And so I said, would you like me to ask if people would be willing to move over
so you could sit on the aisle? And I offered this thinking, probably she's gonna say no because it will feel like a big deal. But surprisingly, she said, yes, that would be wonderful. I would feel so much more comfortable. And so I said, no problem. And so I talked to two couples, and I asked them
if they'd be willing to move over. And of course, they were happy to do it. Most people are kind. And if you ask them, they'll do something like that. I'm sure they felt good to be able to do that. So we all moved over, and the couple moved over to the aisle. And as her husband passed me, he said, you know, thank you so much. I couldn't have done that.
It really just struck me in that moment. Like, past Jillian couldn't have done that either. And so it was really a moment where I realized, wow, somehow everything has changed in these baby steps. You know, I'm a complete introvert. I never would have thought of talking to strangers years ago and here I am and asking people to move over and their seat was just not a problem at all. I didn't even think twice about it. You know, like it just has no fear for me anymore because I've had so many pleasant conversations
with people over the years that, you know, I knew it would go well. Your dad would have been proud of you, Jillian. Maybe he had what had been proud. Yeah, I did tell him this story. I think he was quite proud. Jillian's hands trim is a psychologist at the University of Sussex. Jillian, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me.
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Brigitte McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsanquilo today is Matt Schwartz. A few years ago, Matt helped us produce a wonderful episode of Hidden Brain titled Romeo and Juliet in Kigali.
We've stayed in touch ever since, and he alerted us to the story that Lysander Baker posted on Reddit. Thanks for thinking of us, Matt. If you liked this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you would like to help support the show you love, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.